today we are playing among us with
memeulous courage
wildcat infinite and loser fruit same
thing as before the winners get 10 grand
but winners get 10 000 if they beat me
in a game of rock paper scissors
oh my gosh this will be intense a lot of
money on the line good luck everybody
[Music]
oh my god i am going to get out i am not
winning this
let's just call lights real quick i
don't know what i'm going to do i don't
want to kill mr beast dude i feel bad
i can't kill him and take his money what
what the bats on the ground
is halloween themed they added halloween
decorations look at that oh wait 10
grands on the line i should focus on
that
i've never played this map before oh god
what do i do what is this do i have to
sit here and wait for this i'm gonna die
aren't i i'm gonna die
who seems like the smartest we gotta go
for the smartest i'm nervous it's me and
fruit okay
we're gonna do great dude i'm actually
nervous i don't know what to do i'm
frozen i need to do well
because this game could cost me a ton of
money oh oh clear me member
clear me boys yeah
they're all med base scanning oh my god
they're all scanning med bay oh they're
all stacking two because they're all try
hiding
as well oh no are we all confirmed right
now let's go three of us are med bay
scanned
no reason to do anything do not mess
this up we're gonna win ten thousand
let's go boys squad roll out oh my god
that's so much information for them to
get
what no what oh okay i need to put it
there
all right that makes sense can someone
come down here and do a task or
something come on
do something i need to uh someone's had
to have died
i'm so scared to do tasks i don't want
to die i want to stick with a group
oh this lets me see where people are
this is scary jimmy's on this one for a
while oh god i'm so glad i didn't kill
there
all right should we do reactive look at
them look at this group here
three amigos baby come on we're sticking
together cause i trust my friends
sticking together i love my friends ten
thousand dollars on the line again
dude i'm actually nervous okay i really
don't wanna kill like i'm scared dude i
love how halloween theme this all is oh
no
infinite infinite please don't kill me i
can tell someone is going to come up
here and just mud me
while i'm doing this and i am very
scared because i would really like to
win 10 grand
now you know what i got to be confident
has anyone died yet we need to kill we
need to kill something we need to kill
something okay next lights i just go for
a kill alright i just do it okay there's
so much money on the line no one's dead
how do you navigate this map i don't
know how to get there
my tasks got away with murder i just
heard chandler scream i don't know if
that's fair or not but i'm gonna
press the button where's the emergency
why do i always die first courage go in
there
no mr beast no no no
no no jimmy jimmy jimmy jimmy jimmy
please oh my god oh my god oh my god oh
my god
oh the full crossover carl stay alive
meet carl and chris are the three amigos
oh we're gonna win this
should i just hide i'm gonna keep my
distance from him i'm gonna keep my
distance i win ten thousand dollars
i'm gonna take my girlfriend on a
romantic getaway you're a simp
i was right to be suss i was right to be
suss about him
i don't even know where everybody is no
one's in med bay no come
somebody see my body no one's dead bro
is anyone dead
like hello oh sorry mimulus
oh god finally a dead body oh my
yes
can someone tell me where the emergency
button is it's in the cafeteria bottom
right oh okay i heard chandler scream
like a minute ago and i've been looking
for it the whole time okay i think it's
been long enough to where there could be
two kills
i didn't see anyone up there i just went
up by myself i think i know one of the
killers oh yeah wild cat you know him
personally go ahead give us a hint who
is it
courage what are you been up to oh my
god what have you been up to
i knew it i hate currency i've done
every task but i believe my last one i
have is up near top 02
that's weird we were up there i'd also
like to point out courage was following
me very weirdly you were walking weird
vote them out
i was running away from you jimmy
because i thought you were going to kill
me
hey courage what did you do after you
killed chandler again i didn't kill
chandler
one task left fruit when did when did
you kill uh george when did you kill
george
i didn't kill george infinite what did
you see anything with his body where's
the body
reactor and no one was around chandler
literally died like a minute ago skip
skip skip skip skip skip jimmy's meta
gaming so hard chandler died a minute
ago i heard him yell
if anybody is near me or me wildcat or
chris i'm gonna think you're it so
get away from me i'm joining you guys i
don't care i'm joining what are they
doing
just doing your tasks maybe we can get
away with it
um all right i don't have any tasks over
here can a we go do my test oh no don't
leave me okay
no i'm gonna be a good sport and do my
tasks anyways maybe i'll just turn off
the lights and
boop boop boop okay that task is done oh
no
oh no oh no all right oh
three amigos oh dear heavens somebody
fix it
wait why are they fixing lights
just do it just do it already
oh no oh oh oh
that makes it so easy guys it's fruity
it's fruity infinite or mysteries dude i
just flipped the switches oh no that
doesn't make it easy although that makes
it hard
why would you kill someone on us
infinite that was the stupidest thing
you could have done
i don't mind who just died there
that's messed up how do we feel about mr
beast and infinite there wasn't a double
kill there which is really weird to me
i don't know why they wouldn't have
double killed did anybody see who killed
like i
i just saw the pink body but yeah it
literally was infinite did you not see
his spike go through
i thought you were doing the lights yeah
i thought you were on the lights jimmy
yeah
yeah i just finished it and i saw this
spear go through someone's face
i think the lights were coming back up
right am i wrong yeah they were coming
back up
infinite if it wasn't you weren't you
saying who it was you're so you're just
standing there because i don't know who
it was wait wait wait wait wait wait i
got this
fruity who is it between mr beast or
infinite do you think uh
were you there no i was there i was on
i'm surprised i didn't die
why are you throwing sauce on me when
you don't know who it is all right guys
listen listen listen listen three of
three of us are clear
we either take the 66 chance why are you
clear because you're all together
is that why you're clear we all met base
camp yeah we all have medscape
we have a 66 chance to choose or we can
skip two of us go do reactor right away
and one person does button wow can't
make the call
make the call mr beast no jimmy listen
skip skip skip i don't know i don't know
why why
i don't know what to do jimmy they were
trying to vote you out i don't think
it's you that's why i said skip
why would infinite not say someone damn
well i mean i do but in my crewmate eye
i don't
no the game's over we lose why is there
no vote we lose the game bro they're all
just like walking around
together dude i could actually win this
this is
really considering our beginning was
absolute trash guys you gotta come you
gotta come this way
come on they need to just pray that this
double kill is a fail
wildcat right now is spamming his report
button
spamming i tell you i don't want to die
i don't want to lose 10 grand again it's
infinite it's definitely infinite i hate
these guys
let's go
no dude 10 grand down the line
carl give us a countdown rock paper
scissors one of one one
two three throw six rock i just saved
ten grand
same thing are you ready yes one
two three throw paper no
jimmy has to pay money
subscribe to make it up for me and i'll
see in the next video i'm poor